we'll get to this formula in a second
let me explain what this is about
decline balance is a kind of trying to
get a more realistic model for how
things depreciate right so here we said
every year it just loses ten thousand
dollars okay one of the reasons why
accountants and texted you know like I
think we do this is because it's really
easy to work out it's very very simple
and that's why this is the most common
way okay but it's a little more
realistic but if you have something for
like decades it's like a really like a
hearse or something like that we just
replace everything is there very long
term vehicles right we want something
that doesn't decline the same bound
every time but by percentage right so
what should be done
don't write this but suppose you start
with your $50,000 the first year you
lose that 10,000 what is 10,000 as a
percentage of all this initial value 20%
it's a twenty percent very good $10,000
it's a bit of this amount okay so 20% is
like saying what this becomes the next
year is 80% of its original value does
that make sense
but the years past is now 80% so now
it's why he doesn't thought well if
you're using a percentage it loses that
value of same rights you'd say well next
year it's going to lose another 80% of
itself
what eight percent
okay third it give me 30 mm right by the
way there's a nice easy trick because
these numbers are nice and simple to
work out there was $32,000 have a look
at these two numbers these are the only
significant figures in my calculation
right
what is that times four it's just 32 so
the number I'm going to get out here is
going to be 32 over 320 or 3,200 or
32,000 or 32 million which one of those
makes sense and you've clearly only
32,000 makes sense right so you can use
this immediately okay 32,000 32,000 I'm
gonna lose another 80% this time right
now I'm going to um I'm going to get you
to start doing this on your calculator
but I'm gonna have to retype it every
single time he is up either way I'm
gonna follow this carefully question 50
thousands while you calculate up and
this hit equals right
just hit equals and then what you get is
our 50,000 to display it now what we
want to do is just take that answer and
multiply it by 80% repeatedly okay so if
you didn't say and some times and you
can either go the decimal equivalent is
0.8 or you can just type it in and use
it when you press equals the first time
it's going to tell you 40 grand right
then you press it again and it's gonna
do 32 then you press it again and it's
going to give you the next one the next
one next one
now I can keep pressing it can you keep
pressing it pressing quite a few time to
take note of what the number is now what
I want you to notice is there's a few
things happening number one it's not
getting to zero is it you've gone way
more than five years and it's not zero
yet not only that you see the amount
it's dropping each time yeah you press
it a lot of times right
eventually it does get down there for
how many times did you have to Kris
equals to do that a whole lot of times
probably longer than expected
yeah okay so what this is called see how
that balance the amount that the value
of the table was he was getting lower
and lower and lower
they can you can see two keys in it this
is the declining balance all of the
declining balance at the collegiate
interview this is the balance of the car
is worth and it's dropping gradually
every time now pick up your pen again
now what would this graph look like
every single year we must embrace it
scientific notation parade giving you
you know 10 to the negative or whatever
okay yeah I want you to notice right we
can put some numbers on you we still
start about 50 it writes okay let's call
that fifty and after the first year we
still went to 40 okay so the first yeah
everything's a bit long everything's the
same
okay but then as you depreciate you win
10,000 you lost 10,000 maybe lost 8,000
and then after that you lost like this
and a half thousand and then you lost
increasingly smaller math by the end as
you were like frantically my CD goes
you're losing like cents in the dollar
okay or maybe slow it down
so therefore on your graph here's what's
happening instead of a straight line
you've got this curved line now you
should have recognized this curved line
right if I drew the other side you don't
need to draw it but if I were to throw
the other side see how this gets
shallower this way he gets steeper that
way do you remember this gravity
this is an exponential rap except it's
backwards because we're not like getting
interest on a bank and getting bigger
bigger bigger it's the opposite and
that's why it's decreasing and
decreasing which is why I pointed this
out before when we did compound interest
now you're ready to look at the formula
see this formula right this is the club
just scroll up right just scroll up and
you'll see the Henry phrase it sorry
he's very declining balance method of
depreciation look at that and then just
look up to run a little bit further look
right up to that see that window is why
you do that to me okay
there's a compound interest formula it's
the same thing
it sets backwards yeah that's right see
there's a plus there that's what makes
it the increasing value right but down
here we've got a negative sign and it's
dropping it exactly the same does that
make sense okay so remember how we wrote
this some equation for the salvage value
on the straight line let's write the
equation for the salvage value budget
balance what would s equal tsuki let's
look at this formula now come back on
the zoom in them it has much the same
pieces okay except instead of be the
depreciation which is the same every
hour and call it off why do you think
they call it off because it's a rate
it's a percentage yeah so I'm going to
write that V naught is still 50,000 I've
got one takeaway okay now you'll notice
as well they say this which is helpful
it says depreciation rate per period
expressed as a decimal so I'm not gonna
write any percent here what should I
write 0.1 to the actual the thing that's
being lost is the 20% but you told me at
the beginning and then 80% closed form
when I do one takeaway 0.2
that's 0.8 does that make sense
and then yeah it's fun and then what's
up here this is just however long you're
doing it right so it could be five years
it could be 10 years 15 20 50 that's it
now just like with this you know how
things have different names
this declining balance method of
depreciation also has different ends
when you're told ya sorry you say that
again yeah like six month every six
months work order yeah absolutely
exactly right so let's for example let's
suppose I mean we said 20 percent review
percent reuse so let's go with six
months every six months okay I would
change this are changes we don't losing
20 percent every single six months right
what are you using instead of 20% yeah
it's zero point one isn't it right but
you're doing it not every year you're
doing it twice a year like that um if
you were crazy and you wanted to
depreciate every see boom day you would
have / - you / however many days there
are in the year sixty point five three
six five and then you take while I'm
doing it every day so I'm gonna have 65
okay so yes if you had changed that
period now I was just going to finish by
telling you just like this has different
names declared ballot is the other names
as well sometimes it's called reducing
balance which is much the same the other
thing is also called and this is help
I'll point out one in a second the other
thing is close to Michigan diminishing
value I mean there are no simians really
but the thing that's nice about that is
you if you come back to the formula in
datasheet
where is it when we talk about this
stuff here
present value and future value are this
idea of just tell me what it's worth
so we have balance present value future
value future is lower we call it a
diminishing value okay